you're going to like this video this is
what I'm calling the Trump clown
of the day now during the presidential
campaign the Trump clown of the day was
very often one of Trump spokespeople
Katrina Pierson for example and Healy
Bumgardner now it's a whole new cast of
deplorable characters not the least of
which is a gentleman named Anthony
scaramouche II a member of Donald
Trump's presidential transition team
he's an advisor to Trump he went on CNN
he was being interviewed by Chris Cuomo
and there's basically two headlines from
this video one is getting a lot of
attention and one is not the first one
is that scarra Moochie compared
believing climate science to believing
that the earth is flat hundreds of years
ago that doesn't make any sense
later he casually referenced the age of
the earth is 5,500 years okay and that's
making up the fewer headlines and I want
to talk about that as well so let's
start with this stunning and wholesale
lack of understanding of anything these
are the types of deplorable --zz that
are going to be making important
decisions for the next four years bear
that in mind I think I you know look I
mean I know that the the current
President believes that the human beings
are affecting the climate there are
scientists that believe that that's not
happening I think that the overwhelming
consensus in the scientific community is
that present actions have an impact on
science race oh yeah I was in her every
woman whenever it comes out coral had
Chris there was an overwhelming science
that the earth was flat and there was an
overwhelming side interest you learn
over time the Senate we were the center
of the world a hundred percent you know
we get a lot of things wrong in the
scientific community you and I both know
that I'm not suggesting that we're not
effecting that I honestly don't know I'm
not a scientist you're asking me for my
opinion it's probably a blend of people
and what's going on in the a sure a it
you're not as requested here I I hate
that he got interrupted there because he
was about to say something about what's
going on in the astronomical
something-or-other it was about to get
even better but he gets to the key thing
at the end Pat which is I'm not a
scientist so then why are you talking
about why you think the scientists are
wrong if you're not a scientist that's
exactly why I liked that he got
interrupted cuz
KOMO had to step in there and say i
don't really care what your opinion is
its fact no matter what you believe it's
not chris Cuomo's opinion either he's
just saying here's what the scientists
say and it what is this guy talking
about there was a quote overwhelming
science that the earth was flat first of
all there's no comparison between flat
earthers and climate science in 2016
flat earthers we're not operating on the
scientific method that we have today
they were people like for example greek
philosophers mostly pre socrates in the
6th to 5th century BC Aristotle provided
evidence for the spherical shape of the
earth on empirical grounds by around 330
BC and worse Karamu Chi is particularly
wrong is that the most modern flat
earther stuff was not science getting it
wrong it was a religion holding on to
non science he gets it opposite yeah and
the consequences of being wrong about
something like geocentrism are pretty
small the consequences of him being
wrong on the climate that's drastic
especially the consequences of being
wrong about geocentrism or flat earth
when we don't even have the ability to
send up a satellite or get off the
planet at all the Kwanza consequences
are essentially zero compared to what
we're talking about with climate change
and there's no people who believe in
those theories there are a few there are
a few yet that they're harder and harder
find fortunately now here's where it
gets insane I I want to prepare I would
get the kids out of the room for this
here
scaramouche he says that science has
been wrong during the long 5500 years
that the planet Earth has existed when I
saw this I could stop laughing
so does president like trump and soda
white I just want you to understand it's
not ideological for me I'm just stating
to you what the proposition is from the
scientific community but it isn't but it
isn't for me but you science let me let
me just move on to something else though
which is I didn't say that I said I'm
not you said you don't know about it and
I'm saying the scientific community they
don't and you but you're saying that you
do and you're saying the scientific
community knows and I'm saying people
have gotten things wrong throughout the
five thousand five hundred year history
of our planet I think industry the fifty
five hundred year history of our planet
check please
I'm out the door the earth is of course
at our best estimation
4.5 4 3 billion years old now that may
not be exact but saying well it might be
4.5 billion it might be five thousand
five hundred is like saying humans don't
need air to live that that that is the
point at which there is a disconnect
from the real world here the fifty five
hundred year old Earth things seem to
sort of go over Chris Cuomo's had maybe
he needed to move on or something like
that
that's the headline from this to his
credit he did say human history but even
that goes back millions of years yeah
right I mean we're talking about you
know several hundred years of modern
humans and then early humans were
talking about several million years but
of course that even a fraction of the
time that we're talking about the age of
the earth 4.5 billion years old
there is someone advising Donald Trump
who believes that our planet is 5,500
years old that should scare anybody who
can even put together a coherent thought
send me your thoughts about this on
Twitter at the Pakman